[Music]
[Applause]
ian rappaport nfl network uh nfl network
insider and he's done a great job this
week reporting on all the free agency
moves here follow him on twitter at rap
sheep what's the latest on deshawn
watson ian
uh deshaun watson still needs to decide
uh he is
you know i say hopefully today but uh
it's a big decision it is a monumental
decision
and i'm not sure he really cares very
much about our timeline or honestly the
team's timeline he's got to make the
right decision for him this is uh
this is why you have a no trade cause i
think people sort of assume
no trade cause means well i don't want
to get traded obviously it actually
means i get to choose where i get traded
if i'm going to get traded so he's got
the ultimate power now um i would say as
far as where it stands
i think new orleans is in a really good
spot
um
you know
the others um you know i would say
there's a chance that some of the others
you know atlanta still has a chance but
um
you know i would say new orleans
certainly is looking good as of right
now well let's let's look at this if he
goes to new orleans is there any
what's the fallout
that uh with other
like jameis uh jameis maybe with another
team uh taysom hill that quarterback
experiment is over
yeah well i mean i think once once sean
payton retired i think the taste some
hill as a full-time quarterback thing
probably went by the wayside yes that
was sean payton was his biggest
sort of advocate and proponent so the
dominoes potential dominoes here are
dramatic right so and i could take you
through yeah depending on which way he
goes so let's say he goes to the saints
okay well then jameis winston is out
there uh the two teams that as of right
now need quarterbacks for the colts and
seahawks so potentially he goes there or
he gets a
gets a really good backup spot where he
would go compete if deshawn watson goes
to the falcons then they would obviously
trade matt ryan they have not yet
restructured his contract despite
planning to do so early in the week
um
so then matt ryan would get traded
somewhere else
again potentially the colts
or the seahawks i don't think it's going
to be the browns
if deshawn watson
ends up with the carolina panthers then
presumably they would eat some money and
trade sam darnold somewhere
um but that's probably the one that has
the least ramifications you know really
it's
um
it's if he goes to the saints or the
falcons where it becomes really
interesting
why do you think baker mayfield put out
that
goodbye letter to the city of cleveland
you know it it was read to me as a if i
have to say goodbye letter because i'm
not so sure that baker mayfield saying
goodbye honestly and i'm not sure the
browns are saying goodbye to him and i i
saw this stuff that was reported and i'm
not doubting what anyone else reported
everyone works hard and has good sources
i just haven't heard any of that from
what i've been told from the browns
perspective if they don't get desean
watson they would want to keep baker
mayfield and i understand that there are
nerves i understand it's frustrating i
understand that if you're baker mayfield
and you see yourself as a franchise
starter you really would prefer the
browns not with someone else
definitely get it however it's the
brown's job to try to upgrade every
position when possible so i think it's
something that
um
you know i think it's something they can
fix and i get the sense it's something
they want to fix
yeah because i i just wondered it he he
feels like you know you're fighting
through an injury to play and it felt
like he was raising the white flag that
it just didn't seem like that was in his
personality trait of hey i i'm you're
going to have to drag me out of here
because this is where i want to be
playing
well i mean i i think one thing about
baker mayfield that
you know is
i assume frustrating for a lot of people
but i kind of like it like he got a lot
of backlash for putting out that note i
mean i was getting all up in mjd's grill
on you know on nfl network say yesterday
or two days ago because he was like he
shouldn't put out this letter and i'm
like why like he has feelings he's hurt
i feel like we're in a time now where
people expressing their feelings is way
more acceptable than it ever has been so
like he's pissed off and it stings
he should get to say so just like the
browns should get to say like
like yeah like we're we're doing this
and we're taking a look at other
positions and it's kind of all okay uh
oh just as we're talking uh my colleague
mike arafolo reports that the browns
have been informed they're out of the
running so that makes sense
and he says the team still views baker
mayfield as the quarterback going
forward so that makes sense
well that's what i thought when he first
put it out it's like what happens if
they don't get to sean watson are they
moving on from baker mayfield but you
think that i don't think no you you
think they just bring him back
i mean unless
unless he does something where he says
you have to trade me i'm literally not
showing up which
you know i don't know that that's i
don't know that's where we are
um
you know i i i i would still envision
baker mitchell as the browns starting
quarterback
uh what about the colts
the colts would also like your
quarterback at some point uh they have
options that are free agents i would say
marcus mariota is
um you know a pretty strong option right
now but you know again let's say the
falcons get to sean watson and i would
think matt ryan would be a really strong
option there i would think there's a lot
to like there and i would think they
could probably do a deal pretty simply
even though the colts don't have a first
round pick thank you carson once um
but you know one thing about
one thing about chris ballard is
everybody wants him to do everything
everybody wants him to trade for jimmy
garoppolo i know he had talks with the
49ers i get the sense he is in no rush
he would like to watch this all play out
then pick his quarterback
don't mind me i'm reach i'm retweeting
garrett foley as i'm talking to you but
go ahead that's fine uh do you like von
miller to buffalo or do you like
chandler jones to the raiders which one
do you like better
um
i i well i like both now the the
chandler jones to the raiders is
interesting because they signed him but
they lost jenny can gaque so like it's
not a one for one his channel is
probably a little bit better but close
uh for the buffalo bills this was
significant and the craziest thing to me
uh is
you do you remember a couple years ago
when nobody wanted to choose buffalo and
free agents would say like yeah i'll
come to buffalo
but
only if you pay me more
this was not the case i mean he came to
buffalo
and
chose it over la i mean he chose it over
the super bowl champs now it's a great
deal and all that i get it but like
buffalo is a place that people really
want to be and that is really cool like
they've created a culture where free
agents choose them over los angeles and
that is pretty awesome well it feels
like the bengals are starting
to get that feel that you actually would
want to go play for cincinnati
is that the joe burrow effect
yeah joe bro effect and you know i would
say the same for los angeles chargers uh
you know they got justin herbert like
and it's you know quarterbacks run the
world i think that's pretty clear and it
is getting a little bit like the nba and
not in a bad way at all but like yeah
you get a quarterback and if you get a
quarterback you can kind of do
everything else
around it
right like you can
if you get a quarterback you can say all
right well we don't have to spend money
for a little bit so we're gonna load up
we're gonna get all these people around
him and then we're gonna roll from there
and if you have to pay the quarterback
then you get free agents on
you know lesser deals who want to come
play with your guy i mean it's it is
becoming an ultra ultra quarterback
league in a way that it has never been
before
anybody have a bad week
so far
um yeah i would say the people who have
had a bad week are the agents and
players
of position groups that didn't get paid
by the jet
people that didn't get signed by the
jacksonville jaguars like if you're an
agent for a receiver
and you didn't have christian kirk
then i mean if you look at like none of
the other receivers have signed valdez
scanlan hasn't signed alan robinson
hasn't signed because jaguars gave that
huge deal to christian kirk and they're
like
what's up you know
um
i would say if you're an agent for an
offensive tackle you know toronto
armstead is kind of waiting to see what
happens with desean watson
um
you know your week is probably pretty
boring because you haven't signed either
there's been
some position groups that have been held
up um i think it was not a good week for
those guys
great to talk to you i know you're busy
thanks for joining us again
all right always good hanging out man
take care that's ian rappaport the nfl
insider nfl network
browns are out